yes Steve clay obviously wants it so bad
but do you feel like uh he forced those
last two shots there those three
pointers yeah you know I trust clay I
mean think of everything that he's done
uh for this team so um part of you know
who he is is he's
um he's gonna fire away and there were a
couple late that uh he probably would
like to have back but um that's you know
it's part of who we are as a team we're
gonna
we're gonna fire we're gonna Steph or
clay gets an opening um they're going to
let it go and they've had a ton of
success over the years obviously they
both had you know some looks down the
stretch but you know give the Lakers
credit they they played good defense and
we couldn't couldn't get anything to go
Steve been down
in nine years under Steve Kerr the
Warriors are 19-0 against teams from the
West in the playoffs last time they were
down 3-1 16 Western Conference Finals
came back to beat OKC now they're down
3-1 to the Lakers going home for game
five
what are their chances
oh still
great
well their chances are great yes chances
are great and Chuck wouldn't notice here
with a giggling laughing but
you're going up against the Champs you
got to put the Champs away Champs ain't
gonna lay down this ain't Memphis this
Champs ain't gonna let out Steph Curry
the greatest shooter in that game missed
those last two shots you don't think
he's he's gonna be pissed off
and he's a dog when dogs get pissed off
they come ready to play the next game
they're probably over they're saying you
know what remember when we had them
three to one they came back now I saw a
chance to get LeBron back they still
have a chance they have to go home they
have to play well and they will play
well in the Lakers you know even though
they're three and one they've still been
up and down you know we talk about how
great A.D has to be you only have four
points in the second half if it wasn't
for Lonnie Walker the fourth
it'll probably be time but perhaps I
should have rephrased that for I mean
chances to win the series not I mean
obviously chances in game five when you
go back home I'm with you you have to
put the Champs away
they're not going to lay down like they
even though they're down 3-1 they're not
worried Kenny knows this I I would have
to agree in this respect with Jack but
you got to put them on because you're
not you're not going on the road for
game five you're coming back with the
recipe of success meaning you Charles
said it you said it they said oh we're
gonna play we're gonna run the Lakers
we're going to put in we're going to
insert divincenzo we're going to insert
Gary Payton a second in the in the
starting lineup we're going to go
smaller and and and we're going to make
our older guys Draymond clay and Steph
basically be on a track when you're
running straight on a track it's much
easier than stop go hesitate they're
just running straight up and down Steph
Curry and them so they got there's a
different energy and I do think that
they had a recipe that said I'm not
going to be surprised when we to see a
game six now
now now A.D you know all alternating
games we'll see I don't know if that's
is that a good game on game six or is
that a bad game on games odd numbers are
are his best ones okay they're cooked
cooked doesn't yeah this series whether
in five or six it's gonna five or six
it's over I think the Lakers did a
fabulous job of making clay and Steph
work they're attacking them because they
know that's the two guys they got to
worry about they attacked them every
single time in the half court they're po
because the the words are switching
everything I I personally thought clay
and Steph got tired uh in the game
because I love the way the Lakers is
like we're not let those guys go run up
and down the court and just shoot they
run a pick and roll every time and
they're trying to guard LeBron and he's
going at clay he's going to Steph and I
think when the game was on the line a
guy named London Walker had his way
so they're doing a fabulous job of
attacking clay and stuff unless you
presented to show that